It's a busy news day in Hong Kong – and
Lam Yin Pong is out covering the hot stories.
Media in Hong Kong are busy following President
Xi Jin Ping who has come to Hong Kong and
pan democrats are preparing for the rally
and some kind of demonstrations.
Such events may be common in many countries,
but in Hong Kong they are highly sensitive.
Media coverage of them will be under close
scrutiny.
Many journalists here in Hong Kong say they're
less and less free to report, especially when
it comes to issues like the influence of the
Beijing government, or the calls for free
elections here in Hong Kong, or even for Hong
Kong’s independence.
Lam Yin Pong has been a reporter in Hong Kong
for more than 10 years.
Today, he works for Radio Free Asia, a U.S.
public media outlet.
Previously, he had a job at a big commercial
TV channel in Hong Kong, until, he says, his
editors watered down a report on police violence
against a protester during the pro-democracy
umbrella movement in 2014.
He and some of his co-workers filed a complaint.
That’s when the trouble began.
Those reporters who signed the petition, including
me, we feel that the company was trying to
force us out after the incident.
They will just maybe put you into some kind
of meaningless or not significant assignment
and make you feel frustrated and send a clear
message to you that you have no future in
this company so you better leave.
It’s difficult to exactly pinpoint Beijing’s
influence on the Hong Kong media.
It’s not censorship in the classic sense.
Many journalists here say the methods are
more subtle.
I meet Ching Cheung, a veteran Hong Kong journalist.
He spent three years in a Chinese prison for
espionage.
A fabricated allegation, he says.
Ching Cheung believes he was locked up because
he wrote a critical article about China’s
handling of a border dispute with Russia.
He says Beijing is trying to pressure critical
journalists in Hong Kong.
We have Beijing’s watchdog organization
here, the central liaison office.
The central liaison office will try to have
regular informal dinner or lunch gatherings
with the top management of the media outlets
in Hong Kong, advising them, what to report
and what not to report.
And people will then begin to second guess.
And once you second guess, you try to always
be on the safe side and that means that you
voluntarily exercise some sort of self-censorship.
But the pressure does not only come from the
authorities.
In recent years, several of Hong Kong’s
media outlets have been bought by businessmen
with close ties to China’s ruling communist
party.
The most prominent example is probably this
one – the South China Morning Post.
It’s the most prestigious English-language
daily in Hong Kong, and it’s been around
for over 100 years.
Last year it was bought by Alibaba – China’s
equivalent to Amazon.
Alibaba is led by Jack Ma, China’s richest
man.
At the Hong Kong Journalist’s Association,
they’re afraid that the South China Morning
Post will be forced to give up the critical
reporting it was once known for.
Jack Ma’s people have already made it quite
clear that they want the SCMP to become a
kind of voice of China, a window of China,
to tell the China story I guess from a mainland
perspective in order to balance what they
see as biased coverage in western media on
China and Hong Kong.
For Hong Kong’s journalists, Beijing’s
rising influence means critical reporting
in Hong Kong is more and more becoming a phenomenon
of the past.